uh travis atn taken one spot after
naji harris by the jacksonville jaguars
a lot of questions
about hope we got the running back james
robinson undrafted last year now we have
atn well
at rookie minicamp travis atn the whole
time chris lined up
as a receiver not as a running back a
single time
well hey uh it's cool it's cool to hear
atn has special pass catching ability
mike right we talked about it during the
draft process it's an alvin kamara ish
type of football player
so that where that's where it makes
sense it's rookie minicamp
they're not running live drills between
the tackles anyways
so they're going this is a great chance
or to get this guy better at a position
where we think it's gonna really stress
defenses out
and i would think at a base level hey
this was what part of the reason of why
they drafted this guy here
because you can have him and james
robinson on the field at the same time
and i would think james robinson is
going to have phases of
when they get in town the veterans where
he'll be playing a ton of receiver
so you won't know oh wait it's two backs
in the backfield one guy's gonna block
oh wait the next play now that guy's out
a slot receiver and he's running a real
route like a receiver would
and that's going to put teams in a bind
that's kind of how i envision
you know the the urban meyer offense
working that's that's what i thought of
as soon as i saw them draft
atn in the first round it's a little bit
of the bill belichick approach where you
have guys who are versatile
on the field who can create mismatch
problems
and yes you you drop the pedal to the
metal and go no huddle
exactly you start moving these guys
around every snap and the defense
doesn't know how to respond
that's exactly what it is it's it's
about you know keeping the defense into
uncomfortable positions personnel wise
right
you know it's it's what are you gonna do
oh it's two backs in the backfield oh
you like to have that extra linebacker
in here now wouldn't you
oh okay yeah bring them in yeah it's two
backs in the back but oh you got the big
slow linebacker in now oh look now we're
basically in a three wide receiver set
we put atn out of the backfield at
receiver
oh you got that big backer in there now
you wish you had a db in there right
oh no you don't have him so we're going
to throw the ball you're exactly right
to me that's what it would be
i would think along with that pace and
they can run
both of those guys and know that they're
going to be fresh and ready to go
and keep the pressure on you that way uh
makes sense to me at least
and if you really want to get nuts you
send trevor lawrence out wide
and you put a tight end in shotgun oh
baby
that's it that's what you should do
jacksonville just
sign tebow make him the backup
quarterback and every time you get
in the five yard line let tebow run for
the touchdown and then maybe you can
have a quarterback controversy and like
tebow can maybe
take trevor lawrence's job like that
come i mean i don't know i'm i want to
see what the hell they're going to do
there still i'm i'm very interested
well well urban meyer continues to talk
about yes
right but not and then sunday they were
going to have a little pow-wow and talk
it through and figure out what they're
going to do about
tim tebow we'll see but i
there was something that i saw tweeted i
think by kurt warner because he's like i
don't get this whole concern about
tim tebow he you know he's the kind of
guy any team would want well then why
doesn't any other team sign him
why isn't any other team looking at him
why has it been nine years since any nfl
team has shown him any interest
whatsoever
exactly that in and of itself is what
stands out to me no doubt
it again it's the most white privileged
sports story i've ever seen
i know you don't like that i don't care
it is not it it's crazy
it's crazy myers the one guy who was
going to sign tim tebow i know but
people think
there's a faction of people and not to
blame kurt warner here just he's the
jump off point
but they're like what's the big deal i i
maybe he should start
i mean i don't know there's a problem
here
that's why he has no right being there
it's not
but it's not i know it's a personal
relationship thing you're right
i i it's a personal relationship thing
it's not a white privilege thing and i
only say that because you don't make
your email address available and i do
yeah so i'm the one that gets the emails
about it and i i
disagree that it's a white privilege
thing it is urban meyer is the one guy
and it is teacher's pet and he's going
to get on the 90-man roster and they're
not just going to let him dangle and cut
him
they're going to find a way to put him
on the practice squad they're going to
find a way to put them in a uniform and
they're going to find a way to sell
those jerseys they're going to find a
way to sell those tickets that's why
they're doing it
that's what i believe we'll see whether
or not the facts bear that out
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports